bonjour ravi de vous retrouver dans
extra local cette semaine on va reparler
des retraites forcément mais aussi du
handicap avec Geneviève darriosec la
ministre en charge des personnes
handicapées elle est notre invité extra
locale c'est tout de suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame la ministre bonjour merci
d'être avec nous pour ces 52 minutes
durant lesquelles vous s'interrogez par
trois journalistes de nos régions que je
vous présente tout de suite a commencé
par Pierre Jérôme Montenot qui est de
retour parmi nous rédacteur en chef à
Wéo la télévision des Hauts-de-France et
qui représente donc cette belle région
du nord de la France voilà claire
Stanley également de retour parmi nous
journaliste télégram et qui représente
ici la Bretagne on va dire bonjour
Claire et puis cette semaine un nouveau
venu Luc Bouriane rédacteur en chef à la
Nouvelle République du Centre-Ouest qui
représente à la fois le centre Val de
Loire et la nouvelle-aquitaine la
nouvelle Aquitaine qui est d'ailleurs
aussi votre région ce qu'on apprend dans
ce portrait néo qu'on va voir tout de
suite
j'ai toujours en mémoire des sketchs de
Devos le sketch du rond-point là où
personne ne peut sortir et tout le monde
ne tourne qui est absolument succulent
c'est extraordinaire
la nouvelle Aquitaine et avec les
néons-aquitains des fortes traditions
ancrées dans les territoires des langues
anciennes que nous essayons de garder
comme des langues vivantes nos fêtes
tous nos moments formidablement festifs
qui sont faites des grands moments de
société qui permettent d'avoir une
société apaisée
[Musique]
allez le confit de canard parce que
comme il a été dit dans l'amour est dans
le pré je crois c'est pas grave le
confit
peut-être ronchon peut-être Bourgon
peut-être râleur mais moi je dois dire
toujours au grand cœur alors ça rime
peut-être mais pour moi c'est une
réalité
c'est l'odeur de la nature par des soirs
d'été par exemple où il a fait chaud il
se met à pleuvoir il y a une orage très
important et vous avez toutes les odeurs
qui remontent de la forêt ou des
prairies
quand j'étais enfant dans les campagnes
françaises je peux vous assurer que la
vie n'était pas du tout celle qui existe
aujourd'hui il y avait des maisons
sensanitaires sans chauffage je peux
vous assurer qu'en 60 ans la progression
elle a été assez phénoménale donc j'ai
traversé toutes ces époques pour me dire
qu'en définitive l'époque actuelle c'est
une époque qui est complexe mais en tout
cas c'est une très belle époque et moi
je suis très heureuse de vivre
maintenant et de me projeter toujours
vers l'avenir et le futur
c'est un projet simple que toutes les
personnes en situation de handicap soit
considérées comme des citoyens à part
entière et puis centrer dans notre
société complètement et puisse avoir
accès à toutes les activités possibles
grâce à l'accessibilité universelle que
nous mettrions en place et puis à la
citoyenneté bien sûr complète donc que
notre société soit une société ouverte
attentive respectueuse des autres et
accueillante
[Musique]
alors on l'a entendu votre région
prédilection c'est la nouvelle Aquitaine
vous êtes né dans les Landes vous avez
été maire de Mont-de-Marsan pendant 10
ans mais de parents agriculteurs vous
êtes vous-même médecin vous venez de
nous dire d'ailleurs hors caméra que
Darius ça veut dire rivière sèche en
gascon c'est bien ça oui alors une fois
n'est pas coutume on va rester un petit
peu dans les traditions et dans les
régions dans la ruralité avec une
question éthique et non pas cap en
général on commence par la question
cache ici exceptionnellement c'est la
question éthique et c'est Luc boriel qui
vous la pose oui madame dardieu sec donc
vous avez été Maire demande de Marsan
durant près de 10 ans à ce titre vous
avez prévision des villes taurines de
France vous défendez votre patient de la
tauromachie très prégnante notamment
évidemment dans le Sud-Ouest et
particulièrement dans les Landes comment
la vivez-vous aujourd'hui cette passion
à l'aune des débats de plus en plus vif
qu'elle suscite je pense évidemment au
velléité d'une partie de l'opposition de
l'interdire
moi je demande qu'on puisse la paix aux
gens
qu'on respecte les traditions qu'on
respecte les traditions culturelles des
territoires
que l'on respecte les racines de chacun
et dans toutes les régions il y a des
espèces de sont vraiment des racines
auquel s'identifie les populations et à
force de vouloir unifier toutes les
pratiques de vouloir faire en sorte que
l'on vive partout de la même façon que
l'on pense tous la même chose que l'on
soit tous
identiques et bien nous allons à notre
perte mais le bien voilà animal et
toutes ces évolutions qui sont moins
dans l'air du temps qui sont des
questions je n'ai pas moi je ne veux pas
aborder parce qu'on n'aura pas le temps
rentrer dans cette discussion ici
aujourd'hui
ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
je pense très sincèrement qu'un taureau
de corrida est l'un bien-être animal que
n'ont pas que n'ont aucun autre
bovin
sur la planète il vit dans des grands
espaces dans un environnement totalement
protégé il est bichonné et c'est vrai
que ce sont voilà c'est aussi de la
préservation d'espèces et de la
biodiversité c'est tout ce que je peux
vous dire mais ce qui est certain c'est
que moi je suis dans un département où
nous sommes attaqués en permanence sur
toutes les pratiques le gavage de canard
la course landaise la tauromachie en
général la chasse la chasse
traditionnelle les chasses traditionnels
la chasse à la palombe aujourd'hui donc
ça suffit ça suffit ça exaspère les
populations et ça ne fait que faire
monter les votes extrêmes je le dis très
tranquillement pas extrême gauche qui
porte justement
c'est à elle qu'il faut le demander
effectivement l'Assemblée nationale doit
être un lieu de débat de débat alors ils
peuvent être quelquefois enflammés mais
ils doivent être quand même respectueux
et ce qui n'est pas le cas j'ai regardé
tes pas hier j'étais en déplaçant en
toute la journée mais mercredi soir les
débats
franchement j'ai
j'en ressors
j'en ressors assez triste triste pour
notre pays triste pour notre démocratie
et en fait inquiète pour le niveau du
débat public assez inquiète
sans quand je parle niveau je veux pas
dire qu'il y a des niveaux supérieurs et
inférieurs mais
on ne peut pas être dans la violence la
stigmatisation voire des stigmatisations
personnelles permanente cette pour moi
assez incompréhensible donc ça c'est une
vraie question la deuxième question
c'est si un texte est insatisfaisant ce
qui peut tout à fait être le cas et si
on veut le modifier le modeler
l'améliorer que l'on porte des
amendements qui soient des amendements
positifs et étudiable si vous voulez
tout à fait normal mais 20 000
amendements
identiques au premier amende que les
personnes chacune un temps de parole sur
son amendement qui romantique à celui
d'avant pour dire exactement la même
chose mais lancée c'est facile d'être
constructif quand la chef du
gouvernement annonce que bien des
articles et notamment les plus
importants sont pas négociables je crois
qu'elle a dit qu'elle irait jusqu'au
bout de la détermination pour faire en
sorte que ce texte soit voté
si vous me dites que négocier quelque
chose c'est dire et bien on enlève les
les 64 ans enfin on peut enlever aussi
toute la substance du texte revenons au
départ pourquoi ce texte a été proposé
de cette façon très simplement parce
qu'on a un vrai sujet de
financement de nos retraites et un vrai
sujet de de conservation de ce pacte
social qui existe en France et de ce
modèle social par répartition alors il y
a des méthodes pour venir
faire en sorte que ce système de
financement soit durable pour nos
enfants et nos petits-enfants parce que
je m'arrête pas aux enfants je vais moi
à l'âge que j'ai jusqu'au petit enfant
donc des choses sont proposées beaucoup
de choses ont été amendées et nous avons
beaucoup avancé sur la pénibilité la
première ministre a beaucoup avancé dans
des tas de domaines pour justement faire
en sorte qu'il y ait aussi pour les
métiers pénibles pour les carrières
longues qu'il y ait beaucoup de
dispositifs qui permettent à quatre
personnes sur six sur 10 pardon de
partir avant les 60 quatre ans donc si
vous voulez il y a déjà beaucoup de
chemin qui a été parcouru pas tant sur
les femmes quand même on a l'impression
que sur les femmes le chemin a été
parcouru également mais nous avons je
crois qu'on ne pourra pas régler
le problème des carrières de la
différence des carrières des femmes et
des carrières des hommes
deux aussi de quelque chose qui me
satisfait pas du tout c'est les
différences de rémunération entre les
femmes et les hommes dans les dans les
carrières
identiques pour moi c'est un scandale
absolu on ne pourra pas le régler avec
une
réforme des retraites ce n'est pas le
lieu de régler ça réglons ce problème
des carrières des femmes dans un autre
dans un autre notre registre mais ce qui
a été fait là pour les femmes qui ont
effectivement des carrières hachées donc
ils doivent travailler plus longtemps
pour son décote pour arriver à avoir une
retraite sans décote c'est déjà de la
maintenir à 67 ans
alors à ce sujet justement Elisabeth
borne dont on parle était dans vos
locaux pierre Jérôme je vous propose
d'écouter ce qu'elle disait aux
journalistes de La Voix du Nord au sujet
des femmes et des retraites elle était
hier à la préfecture du Nord pardon
panneau c'est pas encore nos locaux
dans le Nord en tout cas et vous y étiez
je suis assez choqué quand j'entends
dire la réforme pénalise les femmes
évidemment je porte pas une réforme qui
pénalise les femmes donc une femme sur
cinq qui devait travailler 50 de plus
que l'âge légal ça sera demain trois ans
ça ne change rien pour elle par ailleurs
on a pris en compte on prend mieux en
compte les congés parentaux
et par ailleurs quand on revalorise la
pension minimale la retraite minimale
ces deux tiers pour deux tiers les
personnes qui touchent cette pension
minimale ce sont des femmes donc en fait
on booste la retraite minimale qui
concerne à deux tiers des femmes on
prend mieux en compte les périodes
d'interruption notamment les congés
parentaux et donc on ne décale pas cet
âge d'annulation de la décote donc là on
va encore progresser sur
l'amélioration de la situation des
femmes qui étaient un vrai problème même
évoqué par l'un des ministres je crois
que il y a déjà des avancées qui ont été
enfin des avancées qui sont proposés
dans la prise en compte des des temps
d'arrêt de travail pour enfants la prise
en compte
bien sûr le minimum retraite qui sera
qui profitera un maximum de femmes je
crois que c'est ça qui est important
donc tout ça va continuer de progresser
et je ne suis pas directement
impliqué moi dans le ce débat sur les
retraites là où je suis mais la première
ministre a toujours dit et le ministre
Olivier du socle également que ils
étaient prêts à continuer de faire
avancer les choses si l'assemblée veut
apaiser le débat et faire en sorte
d'avoir un débat constructif et bien il
y a certainement encore des voies
d'amélioration puisqu'à la première
ministre a bien dit qu'elle n'était
fermée à aucune aucune possibilité là
vous êtes impliqué en revanche c'est sur
le rapport entre les retraites et le
handicap on a l'impression en lisant ce
qui a été proposé qui a pas énormément
de de choses qui vont changer pour pour
les travailleurs handicapés c'est
retraite à 62 ans et 55 ans en cas de
handicap
62 ans en cas de
d'invalidité d'incapacité c'est à dire
si ce qui va changer c'est que il va pas
y avoir de de recul d'âge de la retraite
pour eux c'est ça c'est que ça ne va pas
bouger ça ne va pas bouger alors que ça
avait bougé en 2010 dépasser de 60 à 62
pour ceux qui étaient un incapacité à
invalidité là ça ne passera pas de 62 à
64 donc pour eux ça ne bouge pas et pour
les personnes handicapées et
travailleurs handicapés pour eux
effectivement ça restera à 57 ans avec
une année à 55 ans pardon avec une
amélioration quand même c'est que sera
pris en seront pris en compte dans ce
cadre-là ce qui auront une
reconnaissance du handicap
entre cinq ans à plus de 50% alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est 80% et donc il y a
une amélioration à ce niveau là et on ne
parlera que de 27 années de cotisation
de cotisation effective
de financement sur la nécessité de
réformer
en rapport aux questions budgétaires
vous voyez bien il y a aussi émerge
l'opposition de porte mais c'était aussi
le cas de certains députés de la
majorité la question des super profits
total a annoncé un bénéfice historique
de 19 milliards d'euros comment vous
donner de du centre du MoDem comment
vous vous positionnez par rapport à ces
questions là
côté moi d'abord
peut-être étonné dans ce cette ambiance
mais
je suis plutôt contente de voir qu'il y
a des entreprises françaises qui font
des profits
d'abord qui emploie des personnes qui
donnent des salaires qui augmentent les
salaires qui investissent
et qui font aussi la richesse de notre
pays ça déjà il investissent aussi à
l'étranger quand même absolument surtout
pour Total parce que c'est pas le
pétrole qui nous c'est pas le pétrole
qui nous inonde et donc ok non de nous
sous sol en tout cas et donc
effectivement voilà moi déjà j'ai une
Satis voilà moi déjà ça ça me ça me
parle ensuite bien entendu que c'est la
conjoncture actuelle qui est à l'origine
de ces profits c'est-à-dire le prix des
carburants qui s'est envolé dans le
monde entier et qui a fait que ces
profits ont reversés 600 millions quand
même donc moi que on se pose la question
de savoir si on doit effectivement
si l'État peut récupérer une partie de
ces profits je pense qu'on peut se poser
la question voilà en tant que cent
triste mais on ne peut pas
imaginer que c'est une que ce serait une
recette pérenne
ce sont pas des recettes pérennes ça
mais ce serait comme un super impôts
donc si vous voulez non mais j'ai pas
j'ai pas ce sont pas des recettes
pérennes dans il faut que notre système
de retraite notre système de retraite ne
peut pas s'équilibrer avec ce type de
choses
ça c'est notre contrat social c'est les
actifs qui paient la retraite des
retraités c'est un contrat social et qui
est passé entre
dans la société française et je crois
que ce contrat social on doit l'honorer
sans intervention extérieure après que
l'on veuille faire rentrer plus d'impôts
taxé des sociétés qui feraient beaucoup
de bénéfices mais pour d'autres sujets
pour d'autres développements on doit
développer des énergies renouvelables on
doit développer enfin en termes
environnemental on a beaucoup
d'investissements à porter on a des
fonds verts on peut faire avancer donc
voilà mais je pense que pour ce qui est
de notre contrat nous devons le financer
dans le cadre de ce contrat en tout cas
dans notre démocratie il y a aussi le
pouvoir de défiler dans la rue et on l'a
vu encore cette semaine troisième
mobilisation un petit peu plus faible
que les deux précédentes certes c'était
mardi cette février je vous propose de
voir d'ailleurs les une de la PQR du
lendemain on l'a fait les deux dernières
semaines à chaque fois c'était toute la
PQR parler de cette mobilisation c'était
pas le cas cette semaine regardez vos
trois journaux respectifs à part la
Nouvelle République qui titres encore
sur les retraites ce n'est pas le cas de
la Voix du Nord qui parle de ce séisme
en Turquie en Syrie et le télégramme qui
parle de ce drame de la disparition
d'Elena est-ce que vous vous souhaitez
réagir à une de ces trois une en
particulier hormis les retraites
et en Syrie c'est quand même vous voyez
le
plus de 20000 morts aujourd'hui on parle
de 100 000 et on bon voilà ça augmente
tous les jours c'est absolument
dramatique et on sent bien que sur place
il y a une vraie de vraie difficulté à
porter du secours devrait difficultés à
mettre en œuvre de l'humanité d'urgence
donc voilà moi je suis humainement moi
ça me touche beaucoup c'est justement à
propos de la souris on voit les
Américains ont allégé certaines
sanctions les gares de la Syrie pour
pouvoir
amener de l'aide d'humanité en Syrie
est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'il y a un
risque de remettre à ça dans le jeu
diplomatique là dessus
quand vous avez des événements terribles
comme cela je crois que il est quand
même humain
d'essayer de faire en sorte de d'amener
toute l'aide sur le sur le terrain ou à
contrario d'ouvrir de nouveaux canaux de
discussions peut-être
avec avec ce qui se passe avec
le régime syrien quand même été assez
terrible dans la gestion
dans sa gestion de la guerre de cette
guerre civile bon moi c'est pas le lieu
ici peut-être de parler de tout ça mais
ce qui est certain c'est que que l'on
assouplisse des règlements que l'on a
mis en place contre ces régimes que l'on
assouplisse cela pour faire en sorte que
l'aide humanitaire rentre moi je pense
que voilà c'est c'est quelque chose
d'humain c'est vrai qu'ici on parle
davantage des régions je vous propose de
regarder un tour des régions de
l'actualité des régions signées Roselyne
Pagès et notre territoire Hebdo et on
reparle bien sûr des retraites
une marée humaine dans les rues de
Boulogne-sur-Mer en dépit d'une
mobilisation qui reflut à Calais comme à
Soissons ou ailleurs la motivation ne
faiblit pas en revanche tout comme
l'inspiration nourrit par la colère
son petit déguisement d'enfant et puis
le dossier à la retraite à la poubelle
qui les projets qui ont partir à la
poubelle aussi puis voilà attention
c'est un terme que tu disais autant la
royauté quand on voulait critiquer le
roi j'interpellé Macron lui dire que
même si j'étais d'accord avec lui je
dirais non à sa réforme parce qu'en fait
il a cessé sous les deux mentir
Elisabeth borne donc toujours l'idée du
chapeau de bouffon mais détourné en
corne de diable avec discrètement à 49,3
sur son front
le gouvernement revient pas sur des
décisions qui sont suicidaires pour
l'ensemble du pays on sera dans la rue
[Musique]
travailler plus pour se reposer plus une
semaine de 36 heures en quatre jours
l'URSSAF de Picardie a été choisie pour
l'expérimentation dès le premier mars
sont des salariés à l'été dernier et sur
un peu plus de 150 répondants plus de
70% des voilà c'est une formule qui peut
être intéressante sauf que pour l'heure
un seul salarié s'est porté volontaire
les avantages c'est ce qui nous est
demandé c'est un peu plus de souplesse
un peu plus de flexibilité ça part des
finition vous avez un jour de plus offre
dans la semaine les inconvénients on les
connaît aussi c'est que c'est de c'est
que c'est des journées assez longues
c'est à dire que 9 heures avec une pause
déjeuner au milieu c'est une journée
assez voilà c'est lourde
[Musique]
autre expérimentation ce train imaginé
par Alstom baptisé corradia il
fonctionne à l'hydrogène présenté comme
plus écologique et moins cher il ne
rejette que de l'eau une première en
France testait durant quelques jours sur
la ligne reliant-tour à Loches des tests
en vue de l'homologation de la relation
entre ces machines et le réseau on a
aujourd'hui 17% de notre parc de train
diesel à travers la région l'objectif
c'est véritablement à l'horizon 2030
2035 de ne plus avoir de train diesel
dans la région avec Alstom les
discussions sont en cours mais pour
l'instant les commandes sont restées à
quai
tout d'abord une réaction sur un de ces
sujets outre les retraites le train
hydrogène de la semaine de 4 jours de le
train hydrogène c'est cette intéressant
alors je bien sûr que nous avons besoin
de faire évoluer toutes ces
carburations on va dire
dans les transports collectifs et
l'hydrogène est prometteur mais je crois
que c'est aussi ce qu'on appelle un
train léger et je crois que c'est aussi
l'avenir bon dans les régions il y a des
kilomètres et des kilomètres de voies
ferrées à réhabiliter et si on doit les
réhabiliter toutes
au standard de la SNCF qui sont des
standards avec bon voilà des c'est un
coup de qui est absolument démentiel et
je pense que des réhabilitations plus
légères pour supporter des trains plus
légers mais qui seraient tout à fait
opportun pour des des certitudes pour
moi c'est un peu l'avenir
qui concerne votre votre territoire les
Landes et le Sud-Ouest c'est à faire
entre la LGV vers le Pays Basque et vers
Toulouse depuis Bordeaux ou la déferte
que vous décrivez beaucoup plus fine
territoire
LGV ça n'a rien à voir
que vous décriviez oui mais il faut
faire les deux ça n'a rien à voir le le
LGV c'est un il ne faut pas oublier
aussi de mailler entre elles les villes
moyennes dans les régions parce que le
bon maillage des villes moyennes ça
permet quand même une vitalité du
territoire et le fait que l'on n'est pas
de disparité territoriale parce que là
nous avons dans nos grandes régions
beaucoup trop de disparité territoriale
point faible et c'est un point faible
majeur donc il y a deux choses la LGV
d'abord au départ c'est une voix
européenne
et ensuite c'est une voix qui relie deux
grandes métropoles c'est Bordeaux et
Toulouse Paris Bordeaux Toulouse puis le
sud vers l'Espagne et c'est aussi ce
sera aussi un moyen de déplacement du
quotidien entre des villes moyennes et
en moyenne des placements du quotidien
qui sera amélioré donc je pense qu'on
n'est pas du tout dans le même spectre
et que en fait il faut faire les deux
voilà mais vous disiez il faut il faut
avoir des normes ferroviaires plus
simples je pense pour les pour certaines
petites lignes
j'ai une région dans laquelle il y a
vous pouvez pas vous pouvez pas faire
avancer comme vous le souhaitez
maintenant
dans certaines je voulais reprendre le
train de la retraite pour finir mais je
crois pas qu'on aura le temps de le
reprendre dans certaines dans certaines
régions dont la mienne que je connais
bien il y a 6000 km de voies ferrées bon
des des fines des fines fines qui font
des desserts
intra départemental entre certaines
certaines communes avec des arrêts dans
des petites petites petites communes qui
sont vraiment de la desserte fine là je
pense et ce sont des voix qui ne sont
pas électrifiées là je pense qu'il faut
véritablement installer ce type
potentiellement de de train qui sont en
fait ce sera un peu des l'équivalent de
tramway quoi je le dis je
un titre de comparaison moins lourd que
les les gros trains
de la retraite non on le reprend plus
madame la mini je suis désolé on va
passer au wagon de la deuxième partie
voilà
et dans cette partie nous allons
davantage parler de handicap et
notamment de handicap et de sport pour
commencer je vous propose ce territoire
et solutions de Bretagne notamment
regardez
c'est parti pour le 50 mètres nage libre
40 participants venus de toute la
Bretagne s'affrontent dans ce bassin le
Cercle des nageurs Brestois organise
cette compétition pour la première fois
selon eux le nombre de participants est
important mais reste encore insuffisant
sportive pour le sport adapté elle est
tout à fait envisageable elle est tout à
fait organisable toute la journée les
nageurs se défient sur plusieurs
épreuves comme le crawl ou la brasse
parmi les participants compte quelques
stars locales comme Cléo déjà plusieurs
fois championne du monde à 21 ans et qui
compte bien renouveler son titre cette
compétition va me permettre de me
qualifier pour les championnats de
France
chacun je m'appelle Adrien billion et on
est ici à l'école départementale
handisport des Côtes-d'Armor on en
trouve ça dans les autres départements
et il y en avait pas dans le 22 le but
c'est que les jeunes de 6 à 14 ans
viennent découvrir une activité qui se
pratique au sein de notre département en
l'occurrence il y a moins en moins de
jeunes Andy qui pratiquent une activité
et le but c'est de vraiment les
dynamiser par une une mise en
application une mise au sport assez
facile là on a commencé cette année par
un cycle de basket fauteuil ensuite on
va partir sur de la sarbacane qui est un
sport totalement dit j'aime beaucoup le
basket et ce matin j'ai entraîné l'année
dernière je viens de basket et le tirage
voici une démonstration de Botia ce
sport de boule apparenté à la pétanque
et inscrit aux Jeux paralympiques se
pratiquent depuis seulement trois ans
ici à Lorient et serait presque déjà
victime de son succès on a très
clairement un manque de de matériel
puisque on accueille aujourd'hui près
d'une quinzaine d'adhérents sur la sur
le club de Botia il nous faudrait trois
quatre jeux de balles supplémentaires
deux trois rampes supplémentaires pour
pouvoir accueillir des nouveaux parce
qu'aujourd'hui quand on a des nouveaux
des personnes nouvelles qui veulent
pratiquer ils viennent pas ils ont pas
leur propre matériel des infrastructures
qui à suivre sur l'ensemble des sports
donc malgré une amélioration des
propositions d'accessibilité il faut
dire que le handisport affiche une forme
presque olympique à Lorient
handisport qui affiche une forme
olympique à Lorient claire on commence
par vous la Bretagne en pointe
effectivement en Bretagne je trouve que
c'est deux reportages nous donnent plein
d'informations et plein de questions à
vous poser aussi c'est que effectivement
on voit du dynamisme on voit ces écoles
départementales handisport qui doivent
être normalement dans tous les
départements qui sont pas encore partout
et un manque de moyens et c'est ce que
c'est ce qu'ils disent aussi c'est qu'en
fait c'est hyper important pour ces
enfants et ces jeunes d'avoir accès au
sport et d'avoir une autre manière de
vivre leur handicap grâce à ça et pour
autant c'est pas encore installé partout
avec des moyens qui peuvent pas ne pas
être installés partout est-ce que ça va
faire partie de vos priorités dans les
mois à venir et notamment de la réunion
au printemps
oui alors c'est une priorité et c'est
permanité de la de la ministre des
Sports également avec qui je travaille
voilà en parfaite cohérence parce que
vous avez compris moi c'est un terme
ministériel donc je travaille avec tous
mes collègues alors sur les Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques en
particulier et également sur l'héritage
de ces jeux et justement dans l'héritage
de ces jeux nous voulons multiplier par
4 les sports par accueillant dans les
sports les clubs par à accueillants dans
notre pays et donc faire en sorte que si
les Jeux Olympiques oui dans le temps
des jeux et après donc avec la formation
des encadrants de ces de ces clubs avec
des dirigeants des encadrants des des
éducateurs sportifs quand ils existent
dans ces clubs et puis je crois qu'il
faut aussi envisager à l'échelle
peut-être départementale de créer des
véritables
plateformes de de justement matériel
pour pouvoir pratiquer parce que vous
voyez le matériel il est il est utilisé
pendant quelques fois un temps
particulier par certains ensuite
d'autres clubs ont besoin du matériel et
bien s'il y avait une plateforme de
mutualisation mutualisation du matériel
je pense que c'est vers cela qu'il faut
que nous allions une question de moyens
quand même l'État peut venir aider
l'état
aidera dans le développement et le
déploiement de ces de ces clubs est-ce
que le regard change au fond en tout cas
dans le Nord on essaye de le faire
changer puisque elle désinitiatives qui
ont été prises et on a les images et les
sons d'ailleurs de ces jeunes qui se
sont ces jeunes valides qui se sont mis
à la place de ces Invalides de ces
personnes handicapées je vous propose de
voir les images et peut-être aussi de
les écouter après pierre Jérôme
va nous en parler ça nous permet de nous
mettre dans la peau d'athlètes qui ont
des difficultés mais qui peuvent quand
même faire ces sports donc c'est une
bonne initiative c'est vrai que des
sports comme le saut en longueur dans le
sable avec un bras attaché c'est pas
forcément le premier sport auquel on
pense quand on veut tester débarrasses
pas donc c'est vrai que c'est difficile
et c'est très intéressant de se mettre
en situation parce que même si on essaye
de sensibiliser etc on peut jamais
savoir exactement ce que c'est que
d'avoir un handicap mais on se rend
compte vraiment que c'est compliqué
vraiment d'être handicapé et même tous
les sports comme ça et ça vraiment de la
force et donc c'est cool de pouvoir
faire ça en équipe et tout et puis il y
a vraiment une bonne ambiance donc c'est
sympa je trouve que l'handisport a
vraiment sa place aux Jeux Olympiques je
paralympiques on en parle pas assez
enfin il manque beaucoup de sponsors et
pour en vivre c'est compliqué pour eux
alors ça c'était une initiative ce jeudi
au stade couvert de Liévin il y avait
200 collégiens qui sont venus se tester
à des sports paralympiques donc on leur
abandait les bras pour faire du saut en
longueur en les aveuglés pour faire de
la course à pied et c'est ce qu'on vient
d'entendre c'est c'est ce qu'on voit sur
les images donc c'est la découverte de
ce
des handicaps et de la pratique du sport
par Handicap est-ce qu'il faudrait
systématiser ça
oui je crois que ce sont de bons de
bonnes découvertes de bons échanges en
définitive
parce que ça permet alors il faut le
faire en présence à mon avis de
d'athlètes aussi
c'était le cas là il y avait des
bonnes choses alors vous avez bien vu
qu'il y a quand même le handisport c'est
plus le handicap moteur
c'est eux qui participent aux Jeux
Olympiques il y a le sport adapté c'est
la jeune femme nageuse que l'on a vu
tout à l'heure qui est plus dans le
handicap
intellectuel ou cognitif donc ça il va y
avoir des grandes journées à Vichy cette
année au mois de au mois de juin je
crois autour du Sport Adapté donc
on a véritablement d'abord moi je veux
dire les personnes en situation de
handicap doivent faire du sport
et nous souhaitons développer
comme le sport à l'école 30 minutes va
être développée nous souhaitons aussi le
développer dans toutes les institutions
ou toutes les structures qui reçoivent
des enfants handicapés ensuite les clubs
sportifs doivent accueillir des
personnes en situation de handicap et
ensuite l'initiative que qui a été
portée dans votre région est très
intéressante les 10 valides doivent
découvrir
ce qu'est en définitive le handicap
quand c'est du handicap moteur bien
entendu doivent découvrir quelles sont
les difficultés
particulières de la pratique sportive
par des personnes en situation de la loi
de 2005 en fait au maximum déjà à
l'école et aussi dans les clubs sportifs
en fait écoutez demain nous célébrons le
18e anniversaire de la loi handicap du
11 février 2005 qui a été voté sous
Jacques Chirac et qui a été une grande
loi parce qu'elle a on a changé de
paradigme à ce moment-là dans notre pays
18 ans après on va c'est l'occasion
d'être l'occasion de faire un bilan
aussi de de tout ce qui a été réalisé
mais aussi du parcours qui nous reste à
réaliser
mais 18 ans après bien entendu que
l'esprit c'est l'inclusion c'est
l'inclusion dans notre société
l'inclusion à l'école l'inclusion dans
les clubs sportifs l'inclusion dans la
culture l'inclusion dans le travail
j'étais hier
autour de thèmes le thème du travail
je vous propose déjà l'école on fait un
petit arrêt par l'école avec Pierre
Jérôme qui a des choses à dire je
voulais vous parler d'un problème plus
particulier sur l'inclusion qui concerne
le nord de la France mais qui peut
concerner aussi toute la France et
notamment l'inclusion des enfants
autistes on a dans le nord de la France
8000 enfants autistes qui sont suivis en
Belgique parce que on n'a pas les
structures en France pour les
accompagner ou les inclure dans l'école
il y a qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on
continue à se défausser sur la Belgique
plutôt que mettre les moyens pour
développer en France l'accueil de ces
enfants que ce soit dans certains cas
dans des institutions spécialisées ou
bien à l'école alors la dernière
stratégie autisme qui se termine là
cette année ou qui s'est terminée en
[Musique]
tenter de répondre en partie bien
entendu parce que les choses se feront
progressivement à ce problème avec la
création de solutions pour des enfants
qui sont partis en Belgique afin que
l'on puisse les faire revenir dans leur
territoire parce que moi l'éloignement
avaient les familles toutes ces choses
là sont des choses qui quand même me
posent question et
il y a
solutions possibilités de retour qui ont
été ainsi construites pendant cette
stratégie nous allons poursuivre la
stratégie la stratégie autisme va se
poursuivre et donc progressivement
l'objectif c'est effectivement
s'il y a la volonté des personnes et des
familles on agit toujours avec la
volonté des personnes et des familles de
trouver des solutions pour faire en
sorte que cette situation
n'existe plus et l'éducation nationale
elle est notamment pour l'accueil des
enfants autistes dans les classes est-ce
que le personnel formé suffisamment
formé alors nous sommes là aussi dans
une véritable transformation
l'éducation nationale moi d'abord je
veux lui tirer mon chapeau parce que on
imagine pas ce que tout cela représenté
pour elle d'accueillir aujourd'hui 430
000 enfants en situation de handicap
tout handicap confondu il y a autiste il
y a troubles du neuro-développement
général il y a les les troubles
sensoriels les aveugles les sourds les
troubles moteurs aussi bien sûr donc
beaucoup de typologie de handicap 430
000 enfants accueillis aujourd'hui
ce qui est vraiment important mais à mon
avis c'est pas fini nécessaire bien
entendu donc nous devons aussi
transformer l'école transformer l'école
c'est avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale que nous travaillons sur ces
sujets transformer l'école pour
accueillir ces personnes bien sûr
il y a nous avons mis en place des
unités par exemple pour prendre en
charge les autistes dans les écoles
maternelles les écoles primaires
dans les collèges il y a des classes
ULIS qui se sont développées dans les
lycées également et nous devons
poursuivre bien entendu cette impulsion
nous devons
mettre plus d'équipes médico-sociales
dans les établissements scolaires pour
aider les enseignants et les équipes
pédagogiques à pouvoir prendre en charge
ses enfants dans des classes classiques
donc ça c'est l'un des enjeux principaux
et puis il y a bien sûr toute la partie
mais ça c'est l'éducation nationale et
le ministre de l'éducation nationale qui
portent tout ça bien sûr c'est la partie
formation des enseignants à des méthodes
pédagogiques particulières et formation
de tous les personnels y compris les
aesh et y compris les personnels des
personnels communaux aussi qui sont dans
les
écolesh qui souffre d'une grande
précarité que vous avez du mal à
recruter
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
parce que ce ne sont pas des personnels
médico-sociaux les avsh ce sont des
personnels d'accompagnement de
l'éducation nationale pas du tout un
accompagnement médico-social sont donc
il y a un avsh pour professeur
aujourd'hui dans l'éducation nationale
130 et d'ailleurs l'éducation nationale
dit d'embauche des personnels
handicapées en se disant que c'est des
aesh alors qu'en fait c'est ça n'a rien
à voir avec le personnel de la de la
l'éducation bien sûr et nous avons nous
avons de de choses en
préparation au travail le ministre de
l'éducation nationale c'est
effectivement
de des précariser en fait ce sont ces
précaires parce que c'est 24 heures
semaine donc c'est de pouvoir proposer
des temps plein à ces personnes
donc ça je pense que c'est une première
une première avancée très très favorable
pour elle qui facilitera peut-être
l'attractivité du métier
et donc ça c'est une première une
première brique et puis il y a la
formation de ces personnes également qui
sont qui sont qui est tout à fait
essentiel et en fait il y a aussi la
responsabilité pour à l'éducation
nationale à la mise en oeuvre de tous
ces moyens d'accompagnement des enfants
en situation de handicap c'est-à-dire ce
qu'il faut des avsh combien de temps
est-ce que il faut des moyens
particuliers des outils particuliers
est-ce que c'est la pédagogie du
professeur ou est-ce que c'est
l'intervention de personnel
médico-sociaux pour encadrer tout cela
donc on a des palettes de solution qu'il
va falloir et bien c'est de la dentelle
pour chaque enfant parce que les besoins
sont totalement différents et donc nous
allons continuer cette montée en
puissance
et nous travaillons dans des groupes de
travail avec les associations et
notamment il y a un groupe de travail à
l'éducation nationale
sur l'acte 2 de l'inclusion scolaire des
enfants situation de handicap ok à
l'inclusion scolaire des enfants il y a
aussi l'inclusion dans le monde du
travail vous étiez d'ailleurs à ce sujet
dans l'Indre-et-Loire il n'y a pas si
longtemps pour parler emploi et Handicap
je vous propose de regarder ce reportage
Sébastien Vincent est électromécanicien
en intérim dans une société de location
de matériel de bâtiments et travaux
publics malentendants il a suivi une
formation au sein de son entreprise pour
évoluer
j'ai appris de
l'électricité et ça fait un an un an que
j'ai travaillé sur
ce en formation
et puis j'ai été blonde j'ai réussi et
puis
je peux travailler
sur les 137 000 intérimaires qu'emploie
cette agence en France 13000 personnes
sont en situation de handicap mise à
l'emploi ou en parcours d'insertion
professionnelle Geneviève Darius Secq la
ministre délégué aux personnes
handicapées est venu écouter et saluer
trois expériences de vie et de travail
il y a des freins psychologiques avec
des entrepreneurs qui pensent d'abord
que c'est compliqué d'intégrer des
personnes en situation de handicap ou
que ce serait peut-être contre-productif
pour leur entreprise ils ont tort alors
la complexité administrative nous allons
tâcher de l'améliorer mais il y a des
soutiens pour les aider
notamment à Gifi qui est là vraiment
pour les aider en France plus de 2
millions et demi de personnes sont
reconnues comme travailleur et
travailleuses handicapés et la France
est en retard en matière d'emploi le
taux de chômage concernant et de 13% un
taux qui tout de même baisse au fil des
années
vous vous parliez dans ce sujet de ses
frères administratifs des employeurs
potentiels vous engagiez à l'élever
comment et avec quels moyens écoutez
j'étais hier
dans le Loiret ou j'ai pu
voir un forum des métiers et ce forum
des métiers il est très simple j'ai eu
une interaction avec des entrepreneurs
en fait il s'avère qui ne connaissent
pas les solutions existantes aujourd'hui
donc il y a des choses assez simples à
mettre en oeuvre des aides des soutiens
particuliers qui existent mais que qui
sont méconnus d'abord et ensuite ils ne
connaissent pas aussi les acteurs relais
qui leur permettent de pouvoir
recruter des personnes en situation de
handicap les acteurs relais c'est Cap
Emploi qui maintenant travaille avec
Pôle Emploi main dans la main et c'est
la Gifi pour les entreprises privées et
le FIP pour le secteur public pour
l'emploi public donc ce sont des des
interlocuteurs qui vous permettent
justement de créer les dossiers et puis
de faire un problème de méthode et pas
de moyens les moyens sont là et
d'ailleurs nous avons nous pouvons voir
qu'il y a un recul du chômage chez les
personnes handicapées qui étaient à 19%
en 2017 qui est à 13% aujourd'hui
toujours beaucoup trop élevé par rapport
à la moyenne nationale mais quand même
on voit une vraie un vrai recul et je
vois aussi au niveau de la de la
jeunesse et puis pas que de la jeunesse
parce qu'il y a pas de barrière d'âge là
une augmentation des apprentis de
l'apprentissage avec
3500 apprentis handicapés en 2017 et qui
sont un peu moins de 10000 aujourd'hui
ce qui est un très fort taux
d'augmentation
donc l'emploi des personnes en situation
de handicap non seulement est possible
en plus et même souhaitable pour les
entreprises parce que ce sont des
personnes avec une très bonne
employabilité qui ont une très bonne
productivité qui ont une grande
une grande
fidélité à l'entreprise et qui ont
vraiment envie de travailler et ils le
disent même quand ils ont décroché un
CDD ils annoncent les larmes aux yeux
ils sont vraiment c'est une victoire
pour eux et c'est pour eux un sentiment
de rentrer de plein pied dans la société
et d'être accueilli dans notre société
donc voilà et puis dans les travailleurs
handicapés il y a toute une catégorie
qui a
dont le handicap s'est développé à la
suite d'une maladie
d'une maladie professionnelle
quelquefois d'un accident de travail
également ou d'un accident de la vie ce
qui fait que beaucoup de personnes de
travailleurs handicapés
sont en plus de 50 ans définitive et là
nous avons un vrai rôle d'accompagnement
dans le maintien dans l'emploi ce qui
est un petit peu différent mais c'est
aussi le rôle de notre société
d'accompagner ces personnes là dans un
emploi c'est-à-dire une évolution de
leur de leurs compétences pour qu'ils
puissent avoir un emploi adapté à leur
capacité du moment alors on l'a vu on
l'a entendu vous faites un peu la
tournée des provinces des forums là on
l'a vu dans l'Indre-et-Loire est-ce que
vous étiez à Lorient au mois de novembre
pour le mois de handicap parce qu'il y
avait un forum de l'accessibilité le
premier reparle de l'accessibilité on
regarde on en reparle sur la Bretagne de
nouveau
ils sont créateurs d'objets adaptés ou
bien club sportif artistique ou encore
organismes mobilisés dans le domaine de
l'accessibilité et pour la première fois
ils sont tous réunis dans un grand forum
derrière cela le projet it handicap
innovation territoire porté par
l'agglomération l'orientèse le centre de
karpape et Biotech Santé Bretagne il
place l'inclusion comme levier
d'innovation sociale et technologique
parmi les exemples les mécaniques
rolandes présentées par l'association
grandiose on a fait venir des personnes
de
et les professionnels qui qui conçoivent
ou qui importe du matériel de mobilité
chaque on dit assez spécificités qui ont
ouvert que il y en a qui va en préférer
une autre etc on est là aussi tout
simplement pour créer le lien et faire
en sorte que les gens ils sortent ils
bougent ils fassent des choses du livre
ensemble et du construire ensemble en
fait directement en fait mais le
handicap ce n'est pas qu'en fauteuil
tous les sens se sont concernés et là on
travaille vraiment sur le vieillissement
là c'est vraiment l'objectif prévenir la
chute et se mettre dans la peau de pour
peut-être avoir plus d'empathie et
peut-être accompagner et avoir un regard
vraiment différent sur la personne un
salon ouvert aux professionnels mais
aussi au grand public parfois concernés
ou simplement attentif et curieux je
venais chercher des informations trouver
des activités qui pourraient être
adaptées
à ces personnes là pour faire découvrir
ce monde du handicap et de faire
découvrir l'inclusion pour les enfants
les associations d'inclusion sont
mobilisées dans le bassin l'orienté pour
donner encore plus de facilité et de
sens aux vivants ensemble
voilà le grand enjeu de l'accessibilité
éclair ça fait partie de l'inclusion
dont on parlait tout à l'heure c'est
l'accessibilité les JO se rapprochent on
voit que j'imagine que ça peut-être vous
empêcher de dormir parfois la nuit parce
que effectivement
ces lois qui ont été décalées ces accès
qu'on aurait dû faire qui ont été
décalés je sais enfin j'ai vu que 3 %
des stations de métro étaient étaient
accessibles aux handicapés uniquement
c'est un quart des gars avec c'est moi
qui commence à se rétrécir avant les
Jeux Olympiques qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qui vous reste à faire pour que ces 350
000 personnes qui vont arriver
handicapés aux Jeux Olympiques puissent
participer à la fête collective bon que
les choses soient claires tout de suite
il n'y aura pas d'accessibilité du métro
historique d'accord impossible à
réaliser totalement impossible donc
c'est toutes les extensions du métro qui
elles seront accessibles les extensions
qui sont réalisées actuellement par
contre toutes les gares SNCF sont
accessibles et il un quart on va passer
à toutes les gares accessibles d'ici
2024 les gars SNCF oui et les gars RER
également enfin le RER est accessible
c'est c'est vraiment le métro voilà et
toutes les tous les la mobilité de
surface tram et bus sont accessibles
mais il y aura des solutions également
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap avec des navettes prévues par
Île-de-France mobilité
qui permettront à la demande de bien
entendu à la commande qui feront les
gares les principales gares parisiennes
et qui transporteront les personnes vers
les lieux de les sites qui sont les
lieux de les sites il y aura également
il y a un dispositif qui s'appelle mille
taxi accessible qui a été lancé avec le
financement enfin l'aide au financement
de l'acquisition de taxis pouvant
transporter des personnes en situation
de handicap et là Clément bonne fait un
travail aussi avec toutes les compagnies
de taxi afin que ce dispositif puisse
puisse être pris en main par les taxis
donc beaucoup de solutions sont étudiées
actuellement et l'accessibilité dans les
mobilités fait partie véritablement de
la réflexion et de la réflexion
prêtes
alors pas le métro historique mais les
les déplacements les mobilités de
surface seront pleines
et voilà nous enfin il y a il y a des
comités qui se passent en 2024 6
semaines sont mises en oeuvre par le
ministre Clément bonne des comités
stratégiques sur ces mobilités je peux
vous assurer que nous suivons ça comme
le lait sur le feu comme le lait sur le
feu merci beaucoup madame la ministre
d'avoir été avec nous merci à vous trois
merci aux télévisions locales merci à
vous derrière vos écrans on se retrouve
pour la semaine prochaine très bon
weekend
[Musique]